the world is a very turbulent place at
the moment and there are plenty of
countries where media freedom is
seriously under threat turkey
where there are scores of journalists in
prison china and russia where
media freedom scarcely exists when the
uk government points out to those
regimes the shortcomings of the way in
which they treat the media they have one
answer
julian assange if you're doing that to
julian assange why shouldn't president
erdogan lock journalists up why
shouldn't putin have his entire media in
a complete straitjacket that's you know
the damage that we do to our own
reputation it might sound high for
lutein but it actually has a real impact
on the the the effect that we can have
on countries of that kind and jennifer
and then i'll
come straight to you jennifer niels
meltzer the un uh former rapper and
torture wrote a whole book on the on the
assange case and picking up from what
stellar said there was a lot of
illegality catalogs in the book
how did we get to this spot now and
apart from the appeals that you just
mentioned
how
how much longer how many avenues do you
see to write this wrong
well it's it's correct to say there's
been as we argued in the case below
there's been a huge amount of abusive
process in julian's case
uh there's been a seizure of legally
privileged material from inside the
embassy there's been unlawful spying on
him on us as his legal team on his
family there have been
unlawful plots to assassinate and kidnap
him it is hard to imagine a case having
more abuse of process and injustices
than this one
of course we are using every avenue
available to us within the british legal
system and ultimately in the european
court of human rights to
put together
the ongoing injustices against him and
use all legal avenues available to us
and we hope that we will be successful
because if we're not
what that says about press freedom and
about due process in this country and in
democratic countries is incredibly
concerning
what's needed is to stop treating
julian's case as if it's some kind of
sweet generous
case
this is setting this is now going to the
high court
this is setting legal precedent about
the scope of press freedom in this
country not just in relation to
extraditions and political extraditions
which the home secretary seems to find
perfectly um
fine which by the way
the very extradition request that the us
has sent for julian under the espionage
act
for crimes
charged under the espionage act
are in
open breach of the us uk extradition
treaty article 4 prohibiting
political offences
extraditions for political offences both
the u.s and the uk are in breach of
their own bilateral extradition treaty
so
what is decided at the high court about
the equivalence between the espionage
act and the official secrets act
as it operates right now
that affects all of you and your
colleagues
so stop treating this like it's julian
assange
this is he's one of you
whether you like it or not he is one of
you because he is being prosecuted as
one of you